lanier you are in first place right now
this game was wild when we first looked
at it after you guys got out of the
opening we thought budapest gambit like
what happened here but it turns out it
was a queen's gambit accepted that
turned into a gambit
in reverse
and then he declined this draw
possibility and tried to beat you
your thoughts about this wild opening
did you have it all prepared yeah i was
i was looking at this line some time ago
i was trying to remember
my preparation um
during the game
uh it's a very interesting line very
dangerous for black but uh
unfortunately for him i mean i i knew
that uh
that white can play this knight d2 it's
a tricky move
and
and
yeah this bishop before is important
because i cannot take on a2 after long
castle i mean it looks very dangerous at
first for for white because all black's
pieces are
are
developing with tempo almost
but the point is that here if you take
on a2 i think bishop c4 is good for
white
and uh then i have some issues with my
knight and g4 once white
develops
so this bishop before um it's it's the
best move and then
it's all by force a3 takes takes bishop
b3
and okay white can make a draw here or
queen c3 of course is
possible
but then this uh takes and rook d8 and
rook device it's very important because
i'm
not only
threading into yeah to regain my pawn
but also in some lines i can go rook a5
and i start
attacking his weak pawns
so
yeah it looked i mean it was very sharp
but
unfortunately it all came down to this
position which is
more or less a draw i think
was there a novelty you played
or was it something that was already
not sure which uh what's the novelty in
this game but uh somehow
i kind of i mean we both obviously knew
the the line
uh it's it's a rare line uh i don't know
if uh
um
bishop bishop of four is a novelty or
which one is it but it's it's over it's
all very logical and i think it's the
best play what we did
is it because white played for this
queen a4 queen c4 line
that
exposed his queen and gave his chance
because of course if you could always do
this with black
no well it's a queen's gambit then you
just do it and laugh right so queen a4
and queen take c4 is what gives black
this chance to to play five gif upon and
then in many in many lines you you you
go bishop e6 with tempo and then maybe
win some other tempo
thanks to the white white's queen so
that's the that's the idea of the line
so essentially don't take the pawn back
with your queen if you're looking to get
advantage against the queen's game but
accept it and why is the move g5
when you see the g5 movement and you
know
the budapest you're often thinking oh i
understand the move g5 you're trying to
put the bishop here which wasn't the
plan at all well in some lines it was
like for example after queen a5 check uh
he can also play knight c3 and i think
one of the points
is that uh
yes that here if i take ony factors
queen e4 and and with g5 bishop g3
included
uh i have bishop g7 at the end of the
line so
i i had this idea to i mean black i can
use the g7 square for the bishop in some
ways
and then black is ready to go f5 f4 or
something like that yeah there was a
nice variation that maurice also pointed
out that
moves like f4
this would be very very painful for the
first player
nice nice so 92 so this was all
well i mean
and i just had one quick question for
you
uh lanier
in this ending uh i was trying
uh h4 and the game uh very very sharp
draw i was trying to include the move e4
g4 is also possible yeah i thought
through k5 and
now h4 right yeah this was also possible
yeah and
any change i thought i can play h6 but
uh i don't know if bishop c4 first but
h6 takes takes
and if rook h5
i think i have uh
bishop c4
uh-huh a little bit worried about this
lineup of pieces right
yeah king f3
yeah uh but then my uh you can take and
take well okay yeah
you might be getting in that very same
ending yeah something very similar i
think happened yeah well for you uh nice
day at the office your your games with
black have been impeccable uh
i like
what you've done so far you must too
you're in first place clearly yes after
well maybe not for long yeah i mean
not for long indeed
maxine is about to win
his game
[Music]
thank you for joining us and good luck
in the rest of your games thank you